so you're a country like China and
you're looking to invade an unsuspecting
third world country like Sri Lanka maybe
it's because you want their natural
resources maybe you need them for
strategic or political reasons whatever
the case may be there are a couple of
ways you can go about conquering another
country in the 21st century you could go
in guns blazing and actually invade the
country like what Russia did to Ukraine
but like Russia you would probably get
sanctioned big time and losing billions
of dollars to sanctions isn't exactly
your idea of a successful Invasion the
other option is you could try
negotiating with the government if it's
corrupt enough basically bribing them to
give you the same control you would have
if you invaded But that is a little
risky and it could come off really
threatening to other countries like
America who don't want you expanding
your influence so we need a better
strategy one that gives us nearly the
exact same benefits of a full-blown
Invasion without the global backlash an
invasion technique where no one will
know you're taking over until it's too
late and even when the world finally
figures it out they won't be able to do
anything about it because everything you
did was technically legal ah yes we're
talking about the or of enslaving third
world countries in debts also known as
debt diplomacy a white-collar invader's
best friend this is where you give these
third world countries a loan for Rosie's
sounding things like infrastructure
projects to uplift the people but here's
the catch see these developing nations
are always corrupt the leaders of these
nations don't care about improving the
lives of their people they're in it for
themselves so when they get these loans
their goal is to pocket as much of that
money for themselves as possible so it's
pretty much guaranteed that if you get a
country like Sri Lanka into enough debts
if you land as Government enough money
they will eventually fall into a
financial crisis guaranteed and when
they fall into financial crisis well
they won't be able to pay back their
loans anymore and when that happens you
out the kindness of your heart offered
them a deal that writes off all of their
debts so kind of you right but the trick
is for giving this debt will come at a
price as it always does and the price
they have to pay is giving you de facto
control over their Nation they're forced
to give you good economic deals they're
forced to let you know military bases on
their land basically you get all the
same benefits as if you invaded without
the global backlash neat right it
happened to Latin America in the 1980s
when Mexico defaulted on its foreign
debts and then almost all of South
America followed suit after and then it
happened again in the 90s in Asia
starting with Thailand but this time
today it's not just one continent or
region at risk oh no no no according to
the World Bank there are actually 107
countries all around the world at risk
of a debt crisis and 69 of those
countries could default on their loans
within this year in other words 107
countries around the world right now are
on the brink of enslavements but not
just any enslavements debt enslavements
but the real question is as an aspiring
colonizer how are you gonna profit from
this impending doom
my name is Jake Tren and we make
documentaries on money power war and
crime so that you can see the world for
what it really is a giant game of
acquiring power you can't get out of
this game either way so instead of being
a victim why not learn to be a better
player your parents teachers friends
Society will never teach you any of this
so we're going to
stay dangerous and this is the global
debt crisis
and by the way guys if you've been
wondering where my voice has been for
these videos I have been up to no good
and I finally get to share what I've
been working on with you guys at the end
of this video so make sure you stick to
the very end
this is go to buy a rajapaksa in 2019 he
became the president of Sri Lanka but he
wasn't the first rajapaksa family member
to rule the country from 2005 to 2015
Mahindra rajapaksa his older brother was
in charge under mahinda Sri Lanka's
economy had boomed all thanks to
billions of dollars in foreign aid from
the international monetary fund or IMF
World Bank and countries like America
and China but the problem was all this
growth was fake it was all fueled by
debts between mahinda becoming president
and his brother taking over Sri Lanka's
foreign debt went from 11 billion to 56
billion dollars in just 15 years for
comparison 56 billion was almost 70
percent of Sri Lanka's total GDP in
2020. if gotta buy a plan on keeping Sri
Lanka on the road to success he would
have to start paying off those debts as
quickly as possible but instead he did
the exact opposite he took on even more
loans from China in the IMF for projects
that would make him look good but
weren't exactly great for the country's
economy then as part of his campaign
promises he cut the country's taxes from
15 to just 8 percent
and just like that the Sri Lankan
government lost 25 of its revenue and
just when it looked like Sri Lanka's
financial situation couldn't get any
worse covet hit and it pretty much shut
down the entire country's tourism
industry which was responsible for over
12 of its economy so in a matter of
months Sri Lanka's government lost 37 of
its income through both tax cuts and
covid-19 while taking on more debt than
ever but president gotabaya didn't care
he washed Sri Lanka right up there with
the most developed countries in the
world so he just kept spending and
spending and spending on pointless
projects and developments and that's
when things started really going wrong
by 2020 Sri Lanka owed 56 billion
dollars in foreign debts and to pay off
all our debts the country would need
foreign currency like dollars and Euros
the problem was Sri Lanka Imports more
than the exports and when you pay for
foreign Goods you pay in foreign
currency so slowly but surely the
foreign currency started to run out by
March 2022 Sri Lanka only had 1.8
billion dollars in foreign reserves left
with dead bills of nearly 7 billion
dollars still outstanding for 2022. in
other words the Sri Lankan government
was screwed they were spending more
foreign currency than they were making
their president wasn't doing anything to
stop the spending or inflation so
unsurprisingly Sri Lanka finally
descended into chaos around April 2022
after the government announced that they
wouldn't be able to pay off any of their
billions in debt at all suddenly food
imports stopped no one wanted to sell
Sri Lanka oil and the country ran out of
everything from cooking gas to paper it
was an economic and political disaster
president DOTA bada and his family fled
the country in July AI as thousands of
protesters stormed the presidential
Palace enraged the demonstrator stormed
into the president's official
[Applause]
anger is rising at the government's
handling of a dire economic crisis the
worst in 70 years
rilaga's economy had been destroyed in
almost every way imaginable and now one
of the only countries that can bail them
out is you China you can offer them
enough money to get their economy back
on track and to pay off some of their
most urgent loans but when you offer
them help you'll make sure the bailout
comes at a price a price that was
shackle Sri Lankans for generations to
come and here's the thing
Sri Lanka is just the first Domino to
fall according to the UN 69 countries
are at risk of going the exact same way
as soon as this year and when all the
other dominoes start falling down you'll
be right there waiting to play Hero and
save them
[Music]
as China used tend to gain a lot of
influence all over the world by bailing
out those 69 at-risk countries once they
inevitably fall into chaos and once you
bail them out their governments will be
forced to repay you in all sorts of ways
from making changes to their laws that
benefit your citizens and businesses
deciding with you against America and
the west but in order to find the
perfect targets for your power and
influence campaign you're gonna need to
know exactly what to look for luckily
the UN has listed out three factors that
put countries most at risk of a debt
crisis basically doing all the research
and hard work for you so here's exactly
what you need to look out for in your
next victim one Rising food prices and
two Rising Energy prices any country
that relies on imported food and fuel
has seen a massive increase in prices
over the last year that's because the
war in Ukraine has pushed oil and food
prices way up making it more expensive
not to just buy food but to also
transport it to the people who need it
and number three you're looking for
tighter Financial situations
covid crisis has impacted so many
Industries this year as the virus forced
businesses across the country to close
their doors Traders are really worried
about some of the things that we talked
about yesterday the potential spread of
the coronavirus and how that's going to
impact the global economy
thanks to covid almost every developing
country in the world has taken on more
debt a higher interest data floats if
these countries don't have the GDP to
pay back the money they borrowed during
covid they are at Major risk of
defaulting on their loans and going the
Sri Lanka way find a country that has
all three of these issues and you found
your perfect victim and here are the top
contenders
foreign
[Music]
first we've got El Salvador a tiny
country in South America that recently
made massive headlines when its
president announced that it would be the
first country to accept Bitcoin as legal
tender meaning people can now buy sell
and pay for anything in the country
using Bitcoin to make the move the
government bought 2 300 Bitcoins back in
2021. unfortunately the Bitcoin price
tanked soon after wiping out 56 million
dollars of the government's money with
it now that may not seem like much but
the IMF wasn't all that happy with El
Salvador making Bitcoin one of it except
the currencies
means El Salvador might not get any help
from the IMF to pay off the 20.9 billion
dollars in foreign debt it owes that is
your opening and with an 800 million
dollar payment coming up in January and
only 3.4 billion dollars in foreign
reserves El Salvador is going to need
some serious help very soon making it
the perfect time to offer your financial
assistance in exchange for a few favors
like letting you buy one of its Islands
to turn into a deep water Port just 2
000 miles from the American mainland
in the middle of what's supposed to be
America's sphere of influence
[Music]
yeah
Argentina has a really really really bad
track record of repaying his debts and
its economy hasn't been doing all that
well lately inflation is set to reach 70
by the end of the year and the country
owes 274 billion dollars in foreign debt
even though it only has around 40
billion dollars in foreign reserves that
is really really bad considering the
fact that the government has to pay
massive amounts of money to import
natural gas to produce electricity
Argentina is not going to last long
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
just like Argentina things in Lebanon
have not been going well for a while now
the country is in the middle of a major
economic crisis banks have blocked
people from accessing their dollar
accounts their regular electricity Cuts
in the 2020 Beirut explosion cost
billions of dollars in damage that still
needs to be repaired by some estimates
the country's foreign debt now equals
almost 500 percent of its GDP Lebanon is
a country just waiting for handouts and
at this point with things as bad as they
are in the country right now they're not
going to care what strings are attached
just how you like it
[Music]
since 2018 turkey has been caught in the
middle of a major financial crisis the
Turkish lira lost almost half of his
value in 2021 alone and things have
gotten so bad that suicide rates in the
country have increased by 500 in just
the past six years where nearly half a
trillion dollars in debts and only
around 7 billion dollars in foreign
currency reserves turkey is gonna need a
massive bailout if it's gonna avoid
heading down the same path as Sri Lanka
and who knows what its government is
willing to do to bail them out
[Applause]
and then there's Egypt the number one
importer of wheat in the world and also
Ukraine and Russia's biggest client when
it comes to buying food unfortunately
the war in Ukraine has left Egypt
without its regular cheap source of
wheat which means the government now has
to use even more of its foreign currency
reserves to pay for its food while also
facing seven billion dollars in debt
repayments in just the next six months
each of these countries is on the verge
of a crisis they're right there on the
edge just waiting to follow Sri Lanka
did and when they do you better be there
waiting to pick up the pieces
[Music]
what China is doing right now to
countries like Sri Lanka has been what
America and the West has been doing to
third world countries for decades now to
conquer the world see after researching
all these videos over the years I've
stumbled upon the fundamental truth of
the world all the most powerful
countries and corporations are the most
successful because of one thing slavery
the answer is slavery but not
traditional slavery with whips and
chains but slavery through much similar
forms like sovereign debt currency Wars
the money printer think about it the
West has all the money and power and yet
they produce nothing they do none of the
hard labor poor countries on the other
hand have no money do all the heavy
lifting and get paid next to nothing for
it by national slavery when all of this
clicked in my head everything we talk
about on this channel all of a sudden
made sense all the wars the corruption
the exploitation the debt the money
printing it all made sense it's like I
could finally see why the world is the
way it is I could see as clear as they
why a few select Elites conquer and
Thrive while the rest of them suffer so
I kept researching I kept putting the
pieces together and I put all my
findings into my greatest body of work
ever introducing Financial slavery
master class we're talking about over 20
plus lessons all narrated by me in the
same binge-worthy documentary style
you've come to love where each lesson
will leave you on the edge of your seats
and in this master class we expose all
of this we suppose exactly how the most
powerful people on this planet have
systematically created and used the
system of financial servitude to gain
all their wealth and power and most
importantly we go over how thanks to
modern technology you too can now
exploit the system to gain wealth and
power for yourself without being as evil
as them and we walk you through exactly
how step by step no matter where you are
in life even if you just have a job
right now or don't even have a job if
you've been wondering where I've been
lately and why I haven't been narrating
these videos it's because I've spent
like the last six months or so working
on this I've been putting my heart and
soul into this and I am beyond excited
to finally share with you so I highly
encourage you if you've liked any of our
videos go watch the first lesson of this
masterclass for free right now with the
link below I promise you you will not
regret it once you go through financial
slavery masterclass you will never look
at the world the same again and on top
of that I wanted this masterclass to be
a chance for you to financially benefit
too so on top of learning how the world
works and how to take advantage of it in
the long term by enrolling you'll also
be able to earn around a hundred dollars
for every person you refer to the
masterclass this is just like Andrew
Tate's affiliate program where we have
step-by-step lessons and resources on
how to promote this Master Class by
posting Tick Tock clips of my videos but
instead of just 25 percent of like Tates
program you get four times that
commission at around a hundred dollars
there's a 14 day Sweatshop guarantee
refund policy too so scroll down and
click the link below to enroll in
financial slavery master class right now
go to evil.university war with the link
below foreign
[Music]